Speaker 1: This is interesting.
The former Fox News host, Eric Bolling, now
is a host on Newsmax.
He recently condemned Fox News for requiring
vaccination or testing.
Media Matters covered this, and it's very
interesting because of Eric Bowling's history
with Fox News, which we're going to get to.
So let's actually just get right to the clip.
Here's Eric Bolling Eric Bolling condemning
the vaccination policy of his former employer.
Speaker 3: I don't need Neil Cavuto to tell
me what I should be doing for vax vaccinations.
I can do that for myself.
Speaker 1: Now we've covered the Neil Cavuto
thing.
If you don't know what he's talking about,
Neil Cavuto is like the lone voice on Fox
News saying, Please get vaccinated, please
get vaccinated.
Cavuto got COVID despite being vaccinated.
He's immunocompromised.
He has multiple sclerosis.
He had heart surgery.
Cetera.
OK, so there Eric Bolling is going after a
khuda.
Speaker 3: I tell my my audience I'm vaccinated,
but I'm against the mandate part of it.
Fox says in Neil Cavuto says, you know, we're
against mandates, too.
But Fox itself has a mandate.
You can't get into Twelve Hundred Sixth Avenue
unless you are vaccinated or you're willing
to take a test every day.
And by the way, that means all those cameramen,
all those lighting people, all those sound
people can't do their job.
Speaker 1: So it actually doesn't mean that
it actually means that everybody is safer
because they've either been vaccinated or
tested.
Speaker 3: Then it's just as onerous as the
vaccine mandate that de Blasio has.
But yet you won't hear that.
Look, Sean Hannity is one of my closest friends
in the world, and he calls it straight.
Speaker 1: That's a red flag.
Speaker 3: Tucker sometimes has issues, but
but people like Cavuto was telling me that
I should be vaccinated and then turns around
and and says, you know, we're against vaccine
mandates at his own company.
And Neal's, an executive vice president of
of Fox, but his own company demands out of
the other employees
Speaker 1: watch gymnastics, bowling like
I'm vaccinated and I'm for vaccination and
so's Cavuto.
But Cavuto shouldn't be saying it on the air
to other people,
Speaker 3: not the Neil Cavuto's of the world,
but the producers, the associate producers,
the camera people.
There are a lot of people who are bound by
a vaccine mandate that they're going to have
to take.
Otherwise they're going to get likely fired
because they're not doing their job well
Speaker 1: or you can get tested right, he
already said.
Speaker 3: And then the other issue of this
whole idea of we're against the whole culture.
They blasted Major League Baseball for moving
the All-Star Game.
Well, that was until they held the All-Star
Game and Fox Fox Fox broadcast the All-Star
Game.
I haven't really heard them do it this time
around because guess where the World Series
is being played is being played.
Half the games are being played in Atlanta.
Well, I'm not hearing a lot of the pushback
from if
Speaker 1: you're thinking he sounds like
a disgruntled former employee, you may be
onto something.
Speaker 3: All broadcast on Fox, and I would
like to see where I would like to see my own
player.
But it and I just want to make this clear
I'm not taking unfair shots at Fox.
I'm just calling it like that like it is.
So I would say the same thing about CNN and
MSNBC, but they clearly admit.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: So listen, I hate to make this
about Eric Bolling personally, but that word
salad made such little sense that I'm wondering
if he's just mad that Fox News got rid of
him for these horrifying allegations against
him are you can you can see the whole story.
It's well-documented and sourced, even just
on Wikipedia.
It was reported that on a bunch of occasions,
Eric Bolling sent lewd text messages and pictures
to three female colleagues at Fox News and
Fox Business Business.
He made inappropriate comments to employees.
The article this was reported by Huffington
Post and then a former Fox News guest, Caroline
Heldman, said he made sexual advances against
me that were unwanted as well.
Bawling denied it.
He was then suspended from Fox News pending
an investigation.
A law firm was brought in for the investigation.
And then Bolling filed an intent to sue over
that.
He never actually ended up suing over the
initial Huffington Post article.
The Huffington Post stood by the article.
Ultimately, Bolling was ousted from Fox News
and the.
Thought was that it was all amicable, but
it is not clear that it was.
I hate to make it a personal thing and that
this is just a grievance that Eric Bolling
has against his former employer.
But what he said doesn't really make any sense.
It makes no sense at all.
It actually makes perfect sense what Fox News
is doing in order to reduce the likelihood
of people being out because of COVID, it's
bad for a business.
If people have to call out sick, it makes
sense to say you got to be vaccinated or test
out.
They are going above and beyond what Joe Biden
recommended, so very, very strange.
Segment bawling definitely seems to have a
major issue with his former employer.
I'd probably be disgruntled, too, but what
he's saying doesn't make any sense at all.
Let me know your thoughts.
You can find me on Twitter at Packman.
Hell of a show for you today.
Remember that you can sign up in mere moments
at join Packman dot com for a David Pakman
show membership.
It comes with great perks, commercial free
audio and video streams of
the
show every day.
Weekdays, we take weekends off.
The award winning bonus show priority on Viewer
Town Hall.
So many different things.
Sign up at join Packman dot com.